we've been given our first look at the
upcoming batgirl movie i'll be showing
the images in the background but before
we get into these images let's discuss
the movie so going by the sneak peek so
far batgirl will follow baba gordon in
her early days as she becomes her
infamous alias batgirl while little more
of the narrative is unknown leslie grace
said the storyline would be crazy dark i
can't say much about what she is going
to do but batgirl becomes her own hero
she said adan she feels like people
underestimate her as barbara gordon and
i relate to that in january grace showed
the first movie still where she can be
seen in character wearing a midnight
blue costume with gold trimmings and
that infamous mask she looks powerful as
ever i use their expectations against
them that will be their weakness not
mine let them all underestimate me and
when they guide us down and their pride
is rising let me kick their butts back
gail year one so let's get into the
pictures now so far we have one
officially released image and then
another image that released earlier
today now the first image that was
released there was a lot of mixed
opinions about this and i got to be
honest i have mixed opinions about it
too like it's not bad by any means but
it's very vibrant looking and kind of
stands out too much in like a low budget
type way it looks very amateur like the
costume but in saying that i guess that
kind of fits the story because this is
the year one for batgirl so i guess
she's just quite new to being batgirl
and this is most likely her first
version of the suit however in saying
that in a second imagery with different
lightning and everything i gotta say i'm
a really big fan of the suit in this
picture here the suit looks fantastic
everything looks good about it it
doesn't look low budget it doesn't have
that amateur look to it so i think
everyone who didn't like the suit should
keep an open mind because what we can
see here is that it actually looks good
to suit in my opinion so what do you
guys think are you excited for bad girl
do you think this suit looks good if you
weren't a fan of a suit did the second
image convince you otherwise like me let
me know in the comment section below and
if you haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching
guys